good morning Millennials we apologize
for the delay you know New York City
traffic can be crazy crazy out here in
these streets but we are here and you're
gonna say we are here and we are queer
I mean after last night's episode about
shrimp our very I think that might be
queer I might be queer uh jury's out so
we are going to talk a little bit about
bachelor in paradise but obviously a big
episode of the snatcher will be dropping
today quick update on our journey with
iTunes and you know our chance is really
not easy to communicate with I would say
iTunes is a three out of ten on
communication I get like an email every
two days so it's looking like maybe our
broadcast will be back up by next week
so it will be on Spotify if you're not
on Spotify maybe we'll upload it to
SoundCloud for some peeps perhaps but
everyone should be on Spotify if we give
you the stat if I link like you should
be able to listen and if not we'll post
another link stay tuned but snatcher is
happening so much to discuss from last
night's episodes we will not be talking
about it on the show today no because
it's too much I have to save my thoughts
which is always hard for me to do thank
god the world didn't stop turning
someone went to the hospital after being
served food at Sur right like the world
is just shook up that we have so much to
talk about is actually a lot to talk
about that is one of the stories I
didn't get a chance about rowhouses of
orange county by twitter was ablaze
really yeah I've just recently started
following like new people on Twitter I
have found that my twitter is like such
a dark place that I've took the
initiative to just like only follow like
positive people and I found a couple
like Housewives accounts that I live for
and a lot of them are Vicki Gunvalson
stands so it's been a crazy whirlwind
couple weeks oh I didn't hear anything
it can't wait to watch but with bachelor
in paradise like taking up all of my
time that's all I can do in one night
that's you're in paradise like I know
I'm girl with no job but bachelor in
paradise is truly a full-time job so I
think I'm getting paid yeah you like
you're the girl with no job but you
watch bachelor race and then it begs the
question like how do people with real
jobs to truly have time to watch a
bachelor I don't know I respect that I
feel as though everyone who watches the
bachelor like finds a way to make money
off of it and yes about it like everyone
has a podcast yep everyone or live tweet
where I can Instagram account yeah live
tweets live instagrams gets you know
some retweets The Bachelor is slowly
turning into like a brand like the
Kardashians like there are so many
people whose livelihood like depends on
the car - hands and
sure is nice and low like so many people
whose jobs it is to either like recap or
like remember when Khloe Kardashian was
like yelling at the girl the girl who
dated Shalom from dollhouse Oh
Durrani Durrani and she was like you
like I see you on Instagram like selling
jewelry because that's because of meat
like and don't forget that LeAnn just so
many people whose careers like are an
extension of the Kardashian brand and
now The Bachelor is kind of reminding me
of that yeah I guess I think The
Bachelor is bigger
there's more people that make money if
I'm not sure first of all the
contestants like from every different
franchise even a grown tree and even
like one girls and then they go to
paradise and like it's a whole business
but then literally there are so many
bachelor podcast by contestants and by
regular people like us that it's a more
booming business than Kardashians right
and as a plasti night look I guess
strangers can just walk onto the island
yeah it's expanding just beyond bachelor
nation it is it's an interesting
precedent we will talk about on the snap
and I have a lot of thought said I want
to talk about on the snap so stay tuned
for that we're gonna talk about them on
the snatchler sea and the snacks are
[ __ ] out today yes she's obviously
just like phoning it in we gave her the
day off we did she's working so hard but
I think it's time because it's called
dash dolls sorry not dollhouse oh yeah
dash dolls great show dollhouse sounds
like a good name is the Durrani great
girl I don't know she was like really
stirring up the drama on the show and
then she ended up dating I don't know it
was before after my more than Gigi from
shots a sunset like randomly got engaged
yeah and he was generation like her
parents didn't like it his parents and
his a McCallum also dated Durrani yes he
seems like a reality TV like Beyonce
like a Slade Smiley yeah you know what
someone's got to do it he's asleep doing
their training Slade's mother's getting
up there and I age like you not he can't
put the deadbeat dad to community on his
shoulder for so long maybe she'll um so
gotta take the place no a hundred
percent and like we're gonna get some
guys who are like what's tins Tinsley
Scott who don't want to be on the show
right that's it where's Patrick so for
every Patrick we need a Slade 20 here's
something interesting like a bunch of
people I'm sorry I have a makeup brush
bristle like in my lipstick and it's
bothering me so much you see it no that
is really I think I got it so a bunch of
people sent me this podcast like we were
mentioned in did you hear about it
yes called bachelor party which I'd
never heard of but I'm assuming it's a
bachelor related podcast and they were
like only that they chose to credit for
breaking the Tyler
the childishness which was so nice like
in a world where like you know everyone
stomping on the chest I really
appreciated their shout out but when
they were describing us like the girl
who was hosting the show she was just
friendly yet I don't know she was
describing to her co-hosts like what the
toast was what girls own job was and
like the way she described it like it's
just so funny just like see what people
perceive you as you know right she was
like they're just like this reality TV
podcast like it's like really deep
rooted that cloudy I went to Jackie and
Jackson Brittany's wedding like they're
just like really deep rooted in the
reality TV community are we I think
that's a part of it I just thought that
was like such a funny way to describe us
that is a funny way to describe us I
actually what's crazy about being
mentioned on that show it's really full
circle for me because I'm pretty sure
she used to do a Bachelor podcast at
Grant land which is like no longer in
business with this guy who does sports I
think his name is David Jacoby is that
is that a guy okay well they used to do
a Bachelor podcast together and it was
the only the first podcast I ever
watched and I thought it was hilarious
because like he was coming they were
really like Power Rankings so for her to
be talking about us now it's like full
circle I'm super flattered you know what
it is it's a clear case of hosts
respecting other hosts yeah and women
respecting other women that's what like
Caitlyn was looking for tonight oh my
god I have so many thoughts on Christy
and I'm like I'm gonna go it on her like
I just cheated me in on and honestly
Christina was the best thing that ever
happened to Nicole in her song because I
don't even have time to [ __ ] on her no
me neither and you know what she did the
tweet explaining it and like it made a
little bit more sense she said like it
was they were all in the pool and like
five of them were like usually clay of
something they like wrote the song for
her they like put her up to it okay then
she said but I do love singing okay no
but that is something I would do like I
went on a show for reality TV but I want
the world to see my vocal abilities so
what can I write a song about the guy
I'm in love with Oh bad
I love you so much that's what I would
have done without context it was rough
but I don't care because Christine it
was worse but speaking of songs Jackie
and I actually last night got the
footage that we've been waiting for for
a long time from your wedding
videographer of me performing at your
wedding and it's just so funny because
perception is everything as I always say
here on this great show and when I was
singing out your wedding like I really
thought I was being like hey like super
cute like I was adding like little you
know it was like kind of cabaret yes I
would have like a little speech before
like and then I added some like singing
you know um the comedic touches
yeah like improv singing afterwards and
I thought my voice was just so powerful
I thought I looked so beautiful and I
got this video and I just wanted to like
to say it publicly or here on the show
that like I'm so sorry for ruining your
wedding like I can't believe that hey I
just got up on stage and looking like
that first of all my dress was so
[ __ ] tight I actually like Nicole
said on The Bachelor I looked like a
sausage casing like with overflowed
rolls and my [ __ ] side part which was
the worst decision I ever made I can't
believe I let someone talk me into
wearing a side part I look like an
emotional teenager so for that alone I
apologize then what I thought was like
such cute like a limerick cabaret it was
like so not funny and like just trying
to make myself the center of attention
at someone else's wedding like it was
mortifying to watch I'm so sorry like I
have self-awareness but in that moment I
did not because I took a bunch of shots
okay let me revive wait one more thing I
have to apologize for my voice how has
everyone been letting me live through my
life my life thinking I have a good
voice when what's in this video I
clearly do not and do not ask to see it
because we were gonna put it on patreon
but absolutely not yes Claudia's not a
fan so let me let me rebut some of the
things that you're saying as far as the
way that you look I can't help how you
feel about how you look I know it was
great with you like my defense I'm not
gonna lie like the videographers or have
great they didn't get your best angle no
and they didn't get the side part at its
best thing also in the defense of the
side part you told me at the wedding
that I was singing at dessert and I
would say appetizer
my hair was still popping like a
sideburn a flat side part is so scary
but a side part with like a wave that
has like volume that's what it was so it
was the timing after I've been dancing
and like had a bunch of drinks so the
side part it was just gravity that's a
doubt it fell no no disc to the person
who did my hair
actually Michelle fix it like 400 times
because I have like heavy hair that
doesn't stay volumize so by the time it
was time to saying I just didn't care
anymore okay second I asked you to sing
so even if it was bad that was what I
wanted but third it was not bad at all
it was amazing and honestly the video
didn't capture like the essence of like
what was going on because like it didn't
have the whole room in it it just was
focusing on you looks like you're
playing to an empty room like no it
looks like I was at like a conference
yeah no it didn't in a bit in a ball
just capture the vibe of what it
actually was that's why I wouldn't share
it because it's not reflective of like
how it really felt um but I thought you
were great I your voice sounded great
and everyone was just like it was just a
moment you know no one was hard no one
was being critical yes no I definitely
felt the moment you know when it was
happening but these sober eyes can
really see what's going on if there was
a sober person in the room which I must
be there might have been I don't think
they would have been like who this is
fetch get her offstage okay but
hopefully I'm just relying on the fact
that nobody was sober I loved it and
that's what I want I'm glad and I just
wanted to say on a public you know the
biggest morning show like how deeply
sorry I am yeah I actually think in this
instance like the Instagram videos that
were shared at the time suffice in
capturing the beauty of it all no one
like in the beginning when I'm like my
friend Greta hilarious it was so
obnoxious and you know I want I was
waiting for you to get me the footage
because I wanted to send it to Gweneth
because she shared my story she loved
that I like loved Country Strong and I
was gonna send it her but like I cannot
send to her oh my god it would tie you
wearing five person wedding yes I look
like I'm at Feinstein's 54 below the
first ever cabaret show yeah but like
it's a soundcheck totally agreed but I
did love it it was great and I'm sorry
this video left a bad taste in your
mouth I also liked the circumstances in
which I watched the video were not good
like I could not my uber was like taking
forever and I found a cab and yesterday
was so hot and the cabs in New York in
the city like bless their souls but they
do not have air-conditioning so I was
dying if heat swamp-ass and then we
turned onto a street that was fully in
the Sun and the the backseat window was
[ __ ] reflecting the Sun on my neck so
hot I was in a pool of my own vagina
sweat watching this awful video just
like making the whole circumstance just
worse
and okay try watching in an AC but it's
not as bad as you think you're being too
hard on yourself no I'm really sorry I
can't believe everyone's your wedding
yeah it was great that's what exactly
what I wanted
it's exactly what I wanted wouldn't have
done in any other way they thought it
was really making waves like in my body
image issues but this video just like
set me back six years uh you know it was
six months ago like you're not that girl
no I actually am bigger than that girl
so that's what's so [ __ ] scary but
you know what [ __ ] it
this rod bar is from Amazon and it's
very stretchy super cute okay do you
think it's time I think it's time we
have a lot to talk about we actually do
have a lot to talk about so please
without further without further ado
these are the Fast Five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast yes it
is and I'm gonna fact-check you or
anything cuz it is time but I'd be
really upset like I think I don't know
if I would be able to get through the
rest of the day if I don't tell you that
today's episode is brought to you by the
real world Elena loved it the morning
toast is brought to you by MTV's the
real worlds at land are streaming now
only on Facebook watch the original
reality show is back and streaming now
only on Facebook watch MTV's the real
world Atlanta is the next true story of
seven strangers picked to live in a
house and have their hookups screw-ups
apologies fights tears voices and lives
streamed exclusively on Facebook watch
if the return of the first unscripted
show in TV history that tackled gender
race AIDS taboo life death addiction
connection acceptance and reality it's
being reinvented MTV's of real worlds
Atlanta is an all-new reality experience
with content dropping daily and new
episodes every Thursday find out what
happens when the next generation stops
being played and starts getting really
on in facebook click on the facebook
watch icon and search the real world on
watch MTV's the real world Atlanta is
streaming now only on Facebook watch a
new episode shop every Thursday that's
tomorrow so feel free to catch up Shae
before a new episode drops tomorrow
great way to kill time after the test
totally premium content okay first
stories the internet is ablaze because
gigi hadid entire cameron go to dinner
with serena williams and you know I
always forget like ggot is such an
expansive network of friends within like
the celebrity community she's kind of
like neutral ground like she's friends
with Kendall and Taylor Swift so like
she really like is neutral she's like
Switzerland mhm
and I always forget that she's friends
with Serena Williams and I think she's
friends with Serena Williams through
Taylor perhaps that's
but I think the rumored flames were
spotted having dinner with Serena
Williams at last Skeena restaurant in
New York's SoHo neighborhood on Tuesday
night according to people had eaten
Williams have been longtime friends so
perhaps the supermodel was looking for
the tennis star's approval on her new
beau quote I've known Gigi Hadid since
she was a kid Williams said at the 2017
glamour women of the Year awards she's
always been a beautiful woman with goals
not only beautiful on the outside but
totally stunning most importantly on the
inside the date comes just two days
after Hadid and Tyler spent the weekend
together in upstate New York crazy-crazy
they're moving so fast like this is
really where it's like life in the fast
lane like can Tyler's he hang with the
greatest athlete of all time I don't
honestly I don't know if I've could like
actually just not to be a brag but on my
time hop it came up um I guess two years
ago I dinner with Mariah Carey such a
great night um my face was so fat like
before I got a new chin now I'm such a
new woman which Mariah was there to see
it but it's super intimidating like you
think you're so funny and charismatic
and then you're in a room with like a
presence and it's not a legend and it's
hard for you to literally speak I think
you did a great job with Mariah but I
don't have Tyler she can handle the
pressure up serena williams like she is
really she's historic like I took letter
all the time I wrote my college
dissertation on her like I'm a big fan
um and I think if I was in a room with
her like I actually wouldn't be able to
handle it but I think Serena Williams is
used to that and so I think even like
someone like Gigi Hadid like when you're
around Serena Williams it's just like
like an iconic person and you're allowed
to be just in awe and you by the way you
should be in awe because like she's like
a greater human than any of us right but
it's kind of not knowing for Serena
Williams to go to dinner with like
celebrities and you just want to talk
like sometimes she doesn't want to be
treated as an icon she just want to be
treated as a person agreed but I worry
more about his ability just like hang
with the gang like Gigi and Co and like
she has so many friends and they're just
like really cool kids and like I think
but he he has to like mesh into that and
not be starstruck and do you think
that's harder to like hang with the cool
kids or hang with the greatest athlete
of all time I think the cool kids
because I think the greatest athlete of
all time it's like there's obviously a
level of deference that you're gonna
have and it's okay what do they eat they
ate at La Esquina
ooh uptown downtown downtown swanky yes
such a great restaurant actually
interesting backstory about that
restaurant I ate there the night I lost
my virginity to Ben
where have I been there I don't think so
it's not a place that I feel like you
would like it's like small tables and
chairs you know yeah like I don't you
like more of like a cush experience but
my friend Lily see I had her like 19th
birthday party there and it was such a
great night I just can't believe that
these two are still going strong like to
me this is as shocking as Megan Marco
and Prince Harry I know it's a fairy
tale Roman and it's two people from
different worlds and like you know Megan
Merkel was suits and hallmark and Deal
or No Deal and so she's in like this
Hollywood world and then just crosses
over now it's like time-traveling I'm
not even know I'm like how did you get
there and so Tyler see it's like reality
TV it's it's a celebrity world but it's
not supermodels gigi hadid paparazzi the
greatest athlete of all time and like
the most beautiful woman in the world
and I can't believe how strong they're
going how much they're hanging out like
and now they're going on trips together
and that's when that's the point in the
relationship where it's make-or-break
it's like if I can travel with you and I
can take a dump in front of you like
maybe maybe this is the real thing I
don't know I just have a hard time
believing you're taking dumps in front
of Zach never in my life but other
people do so I've heard
yep you can take right um speaking of
taking guns sweet also speaking of Harry
and Megan did you see Ellen DeGeneres
put up like the weirdest Instagram post
like congratulating them on something
and being like can you imagine being
like so philanthropic and having the war
like just defending Harry and Megan like
she literally was paid to do it I'm
gonna find the tweet actually because
everyone's giving them [ __ ] about flying
private jets and don't get me wrong the
hypocrisy and being like a climate
change advocate and solely flying
private multiple times a month is very
real but what did Harry and Megan
supposed to do fly commercial like it's
so silly you have to so I don't even
care about them but like that whole
conversation around the hypocrisy is
definitely interesting yeah hold let me
find Alan sweet sorry I didn't I you
know what I'm I'm on a break from like
with Harry Megan there's so much news
that comes out about them and I never
know like what's real that I just don't
read any of it Portia and I met Prince
Harry and Megan in England to talk about
their work on wildlife conservation they
were the most down-to-earth
compassionate people
imagine being attacked for everything
you do when all you're trying to do is
make the world better all right Ellen
relax
nobody is attacking them for everything
they do they get attacked for taking
private jets which i think is
unwarranted and then like any time meg
and Marco like you know her like tights
aren't where there's
to be according to British law like
there's a Daily Mail article about it
but like rely I also want to say
something that bothers me in general
when everyone comes to the defense of
someone who's like catching heat not
justifiably but it's like I didn't see
anywhere anyone giving Harry amply what
one tweet are you talking about from one
random person like unless there's a
media articles like slamming someone
there's no need to it like come forward
and rebut someone who's just like making
their opinion known on Twitter like who
gives the [ __ ] like Ellen doesn't need
to post or a defense when it's just like
random haters chattering not even I feel
like everyone loves Harry and Megan I
don't even know what she's talking about
happens all the time where someone like
comes to someone's defense they're there
like when there's nothing to defend but
it's like okay I'm sure they had haters
saying something about them but like
everywhere are these haters there's like
10 of them on Twitter like why do they
need like a legitimate response back
from Ellen from the from everyone ya
know what's weird it's really annoying
because now like we're talking about
something when it's like no one was
[ __ ] talking about that and now we're
talking about how they're catching heat
it's like I wouldn't have known about
any of this I don't need to know about
any of this like please continue to fly
private yeah it's fine no I didn't think
like when I think of people who like the
media like hates I I don't you know
Harry Megan tone come to mind they're
like pure gems who like to fly private
honestly same no it's just this annoying
thing where like everyone like claps
back at someone who's in not like I'm
never clapped in the first at a
situation that it's not even like on
your level no yeah
when I think of Harry and Megan I don't
think oh they're always being attacked I
think what a nice life I can't believe
she was on suits yeah and Deal or No
Deal no and I just feel like they're the
only attacks they get is like because
there's definitely like strife within
the family oh yeah yeah like the family
drama but that's just part of being a
royal Kate got that - Diana lets me now
Africa yeah totally
back to Gigi and Tyler I had another
thought about then oh speaking of dumps
do you see Jordan Rogers story this
morning no oh my god we watch it what
does it make me throw up you're
literally gonna be so uncomfortable I'm
not even gonna go I stay to watch it I'm
gonna watch it from girls man and you
can it's just skills with text on top so
you can read it out loud and I'm really
sorry that everyone has to suffer
through
but Margo sent it to me this morning and
I had to suffer through it like it's
from this morning before I even brushed
my teeth
therefore you all need to hear about
this because I'm seriously alarmed best
30,000 foot poop tip yeah wait hold on
do you not see it did he put a picture
of his food no I think maybe it's not
here
oh my gosh it's gone what was it okay he
did this whole chronicle of text over
image I'm gonna sit down he pooped on a
plane and which is his biggest like fear
in life buddy I had to go so badly he
was worried he was gonna slide out of
him in his seat like so [ __ ]
descriptive then he goes to the bathroom
and he was like worried that he was
gonna have to clean it up like his fear
about pooping on planes in general and
then something happened where like his
innate person sitting next him like came
or whatever and it was all about like
[ __ ] on a plane - no disgusting well
speaking of [ __ ] on the plane you
know what it actually is my worst
nightmare I don't think I ever have or
ever will because there's no water in
the bone there's something weird about
being so close to your own poop I think
that was his concern that there's no
water in the bowl so like do you have to
clean it off yourself well that's dumb
does you know how to oil it's work but
no it's just like the thought of like
okay you poop and then like your poop is
just like right there apologies for the
background noise we're having a little
construction at the studio you know
expanding yeah prestige worldwide as it
has invested in us and we're just you
know blowing it up this snatchler it's
just taking us to new levels we never
thought we could get to
that's disgusting it was disgusting I
don't know if he deleted it or expired
oh is from yesterday so it expired but
there's some there was something so
wrong with it was it a live story of him
being on a plane or just like talking
about pooping in general a live story of
him being on a plane and I didn't finish
watching because I had to go vomit but
something happened where like the it was
embarrassing for him in some way I'm not
interested to know how how embarrassment
gonna be if you're blessing on your
Instagram with a million followers makes
you think sometimes something
embarrassing happens saying you feel
like the only way to like get ahead of
get through it is to tell people make it
like less bad because at least you
didn't go through it alone yeah like
Jordan Osric psychic don't give a [ __ ]
about your [ __ ] I was like when I told
everyone I pooped on the ferry yes but
that was just really an important detail
for how clean the ferry honestly and you
know
I was with you I didn't even know that
you knew something interesting you
should know by me it's like I'm the
quickest pooper like the way that people
will take like a people who like pee
really long and they take a long time
putting up their pants and like washing
their hands six times that's how long I
could poop in nice girls appealing ten
seconds very cool but in fact I have
interesting bowels uh anyways Tyler and
Gigi like we haven't spoken about them
since like we broke the news and I just
can't believe it's it's on poppin I
can't believe a that it's real like not
just like they met for coffee one time
that it's real relationship they keep
they don't seem like they're doing a
very good job of hiding from the
paparazzi let me discuss on yesterday's
episode like it what celebrity wants to
be private Jamie Foxx and Katie Holmes
they can be I like they of doing a
pretty good job because all these photos
that were getting are not paparazzi
photos they're like random people at
Starbucks in Malta New York who are
taking pictures and putting it in the
morning toast like it's not professional
right that's true and even when a
paparazzi gets a photo of them like
they're never together it's always them
in the same place but not together
they're do they do a pretty good job of
it well now let me ask you something
because that's what we said about Sean
and Camila was like all the photos we
were seeing of them were like in toast
your scripts them just like sitting on
restaurants making out like not actual
paparazzi like where their publicist
staged the whole thing so now that we're
like a month out of the Sean and Camila
thing do you still think it's real uh I
don't know I don't know where I landed
because yes we were seeing toasters
suppose we were also seeing paparazzi
stuff so I don't know if it was just it
was full like full steam ahead on the
publicity stunt yeah no I was very much
on board of it being a real thing and
now I ain't so sure I'm concerned but
you know I thought Nick and Priyanka
weren't real and now the more I see the
more I think like actually they might be
legally married so um it just teaches me
like I don't know nothing I don't know
anything you don't know anything it's
crazy it's crazy and you know it's also
my gonca will always be something that
will make me like question everybody no
no and just like if I think something I
need to be reminded oh you thought this
might make from Priyanka maybe you're
wrong yeah usually right it's just it's
good that's also what like being
cancelled does to you oh for sure like
when when someone gets cancelled like bc
before our cancellation when someone
gets cancelled i was like yeah you saw
look yeah everyone's right you [ __ ]
suck like tweeting me things at people
but then being on the other side
you know there actually is a you know
two sides to every story now every time
someone's gets canceled my immediate
reaction is to be like what do they have
to say yeah listen to them first and
then if I determine they deserve to be
canceled get it so so what do they have
to say but also how are they doing
because I feel like sometimes people go
through it and deservedly like you know
they did something wrong but are they
okay like it's you're still a person
right and you know kill anyone and like
a lot of times the people that get
cancelled or like go through this aren't
your traditional celebrities most of the
time it's people on the internet like
even Bachelor people even looking at
like Blake and the Caitlyn thing like
I'm just like are they okay they're
actually just regular people right they
don't have mansions to cry and no you
know so where Jordan woods it's like I
didn't agree with what she did and I I'm
not happy about it but what's she okay
no totally it's just like she came in
her home like yeah no totally there's
like a side of castle culture that Leigh
is like it's so deeply sad yeah it's
also you know what it is it's like it's
an unemployed it's like firing someone
it's right you know it you don't and not
everyone shares when someone loses their
job right that's what you're doing right
and that's what it is it's like what the
people who usually are getting cancelled
okay when Kevin Spacey got canceled like
he'll be fine his mansions to spare but
it's like the people were usually
getting cancelled are like creators are
people who are like young entrepreneurs
who are like constantly trying to build
their business and like getting
cancelled it's like getting fired I'm
like without severance and without
unemployment checks from the government
like right and so everyone is always
like sad when there's layoffs and
unemployment rates are rising but like
then we're happy about cancellations
yeah it doesn't add up
no it does not add up I'm doing the math
and 1/8 adding up ok Dancing with the
Stars cast has been announced oh my gosh
I'm actually really excited about it I
was talking with Margo yesterday I think
I actually might watch Dancing with the
Stars I might you so here are some of
the new cast members Hannah brown which
we new james van der beek
love ray lewis looks like a football
player
Lamar Odom I know looks like a
basketball player looks like a former
basketball player
Kurama Brown yeah love Lauren Elena I
know incredible hold on Sean Spicer
so weird Kate Flannery she's from the
office ok cute christie brinkley super
cute ok yes I think she'd be better than
that but she might be but I
it's just a fun thing for her to do you
know and also your star always rises
from dead ends when the stars look at
Rumer Willis know it's real Bristol
Palin crazy Kel Mitchell from Kenan &
Kel oh my gosh Mary Wilson and Ally
Brooke Hernandez from harmony so now
it's like I feel like they did a really
good job this season of not having any
controversial people where it's like
Simone biles being on Dancing with the
Stars Dancing is another version of
gymnastics like she's a professional
gymnast that's like when Heather Martin
that's what we were saying with the Glee
people so feel like nobody in this group
really filter Mike finds himself in a
pickle
except maybe Ally Brooke like doing that
death a fifth harmony like girl band
choreography like it's really good
process when normanni went on Dancing
with the Stars like she crushed it
oh because they're really talented
dancers so she has the advantage here
but that doesn't always mean a win
also normanni had two advantages one she
was like a really great dancer from her
experience in fifth harmony and she had
an enormous fan base like the mommy
stands will kill you in your sleep in
I don't know but Ally Brooke fans are
just not there no but she still has
faith harmony fans and I think she'll do
really well um I am endorsing Lauren
Alaina like I'm actually I think this
would be so great for her like this is
just first of all like I know her as
literally the most talented singer ever
and like the people who love country do
but like America it's got to see it now
and I just hope she does one song where
she sinks herself oh just dance but I
hope she's dancing to all her own songs
because they need to get out there
because I need them playing like more I
need more people to get on the Laura Lee
you know Stan tree and I really actually
like the versions like that Dancing with
the Stars uses the songs did you like
stripped down to acoustic versions of
every song and it's really beautiful
I've never in full watched an episode of
Dancing with the Stars I've watch one
like someone I liked was performing like
a song or something but this is gonna be
great I actually think I might tune in
is it two hours I don't know it's like
an ABC to our reality show with twice a
week oh god there's so much life because
you want to vote before voting closes
and this really reminds me of like when
we were younger growing up like American
Idol like with the voting like it was so
many hours like me who lived for it and
then remember the finale or they always
had like giving back week they would
make you cry you know to call all the
time on the landline yeah for our
favorite content we are like partially
responsible for the careers of Carrie
Underwood and Kelly Clarkson yeah and
Diane
garma weed and Francesca Purina yeah she
was an icon
totally icons only I agree I might watch
dip in and out everyone's excited about
Hanabi I'm excited for her except I'm
just like still ever since that
Instagram posts that she posted I'm just
worried about her
also what she doesn't have a person with
her to go through all of this newfound
fame with who are you thinking about
right now
three two one he the risco like justice
for Kaitlyn Bristowe she ever gonna go
on Dancing with the Stars she got she
was a first bachelor contestant to ever
get offered she was a [ __ ] dancer no
there had been previous bachelors so
we've gone on yeah but then Mike slice
made a rule like that time that that's
not what people should be doing Chris
soules went on before but after he was a
bachelor I'm pretty sure I think that
whatever like justice for he shall know
went on did go on crazy mm-hmm crazy
times I feel like she should still the
door is still open like she's still
relevant she should go on and she's like
in The Bachelor ABC good graces yeah she
should and my place is out like he
abuses his wife so who gives a [ __ ] what
he thinks so true I think what's gonna
be is your wife like what you say
doesn't matter yeah I think Kate like
range to start petitioning and we should
be petitioning for her I agree because
she's actually such a good dancer like I
know that they're no longer together
remember remember when her and Sean
booth used to go and crash weddings and
like dance like animals that was so fun
those for a good time yeah that was like
a good time in my life yeah my room I
was having fun and I was watching them
have fun and it was I I only have fond
memories
it was just like fun all around yeah
yeah my back it's [ __ ] killing me you
know I got a new purple mattress and
last night I did not sleep on it and I'm
just my back is breaking my belts too
tight my hips are shaken from left to
right you've got to stick with purple I
know if you're struggling to get a good
night's sleep you've got to try purple
mattress their company history the
founders believe they're two brothers
who have been developing cushioning
technology for 30 years on things like
medical beds and wheelchairs but in 2016
they finally decided to use their
patented comfort technology to create
purple the world's most scientific
mattress it will probably feel different
than anything you've ever experienced
because it uses a brand new material
that was developed by an actual rocket
scientist and you know what I feel as
though that is an appropriate person to
be making a bed because the complexities
of getting a good night's rest are so
complex that the only person smart
enough is a Rockets
it's a science getting a good night's
sleep the per bullet material feels very
unique because it's both firm and soft
at the same time so it keeps everything
supported while still feeling really
comfortable plus it's breathable so it
sleeps cool and the air conditioning
also went out went out in my apartment
um last night which is why I didn't
sleep in my apartment I'm having a lot
of problems in my apartment and it
really emphasizes the importance of
cooling technology in a mattress because
I'm a sweaty sweaty sleeper and it's
short dress they give you a hundred nice
a hundred night risk-free trial because
if you're not fully satisfied you can
return your mattress for a full refund
backed by a ten year warranty free
shipping and returns free in-home setup
and no mattress removal
you're gonna love purple and right now
our listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress I
love my purple pillow that's in addition
to the great gifts they're only offering
site-wide just text toast to eight four
eight eight eight the only way to get
this free pillow with purchase of
mattress is to text tio ast two eight
four eight eight eight
again that's toast to 84 eight eight
eight check it out you'll love it sign
on sleep amazing I wish ya
pillows are important I don't think I've
ever woken up in the morning and someone
been like how do you feel and I said
good no never I don't know like what the
right amount of sleep for me is like how
to wake up even when I wake up naturally
like I just yeah like I could I could
keep sleeping the only time I you like
get out of bed is because it's like one
o'clock I'm like oh I shouldn't get out
wait does you think it's the right thing
to do yeah but otherwise I could go all
day yeah me too
all day every day well I'm really
looking forward to watching Sean Spicer
shaking that thing I got to see you out
there shake that thang honestly like
that's embarrassing he should like he
should not know truly embarrassing it's
awful honestly family right yeah these
are your fans of the show maybe did
scare Moochie go on I don't know it's
like a famous yeah I don't think he went
on he was famous and now his wife's
trying to get on Real Housewives of New
York I know so sad and I don't think
it's gonna happen nor should it no me
neither
oh my god wait did you see Tori Spelling
and Jennie Garth I'm watching Evans live
yes did you see when Tori Spelling was
like literally begging to be a housewife
and then she said that Jennie Garth had
been asked a few years ago yes and I'm
begging you on my hands and knees please
don't allow Tori Spelling to become a
housewife like that will do me
especially the Beverly Hills they're so
elevated like honestly she's trash she's
been on TV forever like she has a
reality show it's not on anymore
I don't know it's because she's not good
I'm not like please no yeah please my
foot down me Denise Richards was the
last of the TV stars Tori Spelling also
had such a weird like life you know like
she is like an heiress right but with no
money I think she has money but yeah
it's a mom took it it's weird because
I've been spelling her dad was a [ __ ]
creator of seventh heaven I know and I'm
sure other things but no but they had
that house
Candyland cuz her mom's name is candy
actually just sold crazy yeah it was
like the biggest most expensive house
one of the biggest and most expensive
houses in the country Wow I was just
reading about honey yeah congratulations
to the buyer if you're a toaster invite
us for a pool party yeah totally
or men who bought it like your
daughter's a toaster like we'll come
sleep over yeah we'll come to a private
performance yeah yeah live stream okay
next up some happy news
Aaron Foster is engaged oh my god I saw
and you know it's so crazy like how
everyone must have been so happy is that
the news was broken on Sarah's Instagram
like when you're getting gauged like you
want to be the one to post about it but
they were all just so happy that you
just posted you know yeah that's pretty
much your ejaculation honestly that was
like us at Olivia's engagement we were
all like sending their hands shaking
from adrenaline so exciting like trying
to post a photo trying to get a photo
that was like really actually stressful
ya know it's very stressful cuz you
don't the person to see but you want to
get it up in time you wanna be the last
one
yeah but the ring oh my god beautiful
beautiful [ __ ] huge I don't know how
many carats but it's just [ __ ] huge
with a like a very thin gold band she
looks very happy I have met Simon lovely
man Sarah great girl happy for everyone
all around Oh her ring is from the
jeweler James Schultz it's not Kyle
Chang no and we're told it's roughly
five carats
Wow Simon nice nice beautiful I'm really
happy for her yes she was like kind of
um like a Carrie Bradshaw like the last
single girl you know like thing you know
and so I don't know what she's gonna
Instagram about now but I'm really
excited I'm excited to see her as like a
bride in training because um it's
[ __ ] torturous and I'm sure she'll be
really funny about it yeah and also
there's just like so many simplice
happening in the foster family as of
late katharine mcphee foster getting
married to David just good news all
around I'm very excited
just isn't it weird probably to like get
married like the same year as your dad
no yeah definitely I guess that's what
happens when your dad is a fox yeah
everyone just wants to snatch him up
like the snatchler it's 11:11 make a
wish I wish oh the snatcher would get
back on iTunes honestly that's such a
personal wish oh yeah but if it comes
true well no it was the 1111 cards
that's not 11:11 started here at the
show oh my god it has to tell you their
craziest thing maybe you won't think
it's so crazy but you just reminded me
of something so I told you last night I
met your conditioning wasn't working so
I stopped with Margo and you know when
you're sleeping with someone like you
can't fall asleep you just want to talk
and me and Margo were in bed talking and
she was like let's play a game like you
know I like good games and it's true I
do know all the good games so I'm like
let's play the game
odds have you ever played no ok so
Jackie what are the odds right now that
you'll show your butt cheeks to the
audience like one in a thousand cheeks
okay so now the game was like you and I
both have to think of a number one 300
and say it on the count of three and if
we both say the same same number then
you have to share your butt cheeks oh my
god Margo I was like I don't know why
I'm always thinking about cheeks it's
like Margo what are the odds that you
will go put your red cheeks about 100
like it sound that crazy so he said one
two three and I just had top mark in
this game and we both said 23 and like
we were freaking on the bed like that's
so weird right like I just taught her
the game and all the numbers we both
said 22 and we were in the bed like
freaking out like there was a ghost like
there goes to see just that ya know it
was so odd okay so your butt cheeks your
audience on the count of three say
number between 100 okay one two three
it's just touching fun game and you just
remind him because you were saying it's
like if we know 11:11 it's like meant to
be and like that was totally meant to be
yeah Wow crazy it was like we were
freaking out I'm sure you guys are
freaks
okay next story is a bit of a twofer
because there's been some men from rules
and news yes first story Lisa
Vanderpump's restaurant blast guests
claiming they got sick and defecated on
the floor was it Jordan Rogers
according to court documents a woman
claimed to have gotten violently ill
after eating quote whitefish covered
with an orange cream sauce Lisa
Vanderpump's famed restaurant sir is
firing back at a woman who filed a
lawsuit against
claiming to a gotten so intensely ill
while eating there two years ago that
she began to perfuse li vomit before
defecating on the floor oh so she's
saying this happened two years ago yes
quote fish a sir has been in business
for 15 years and serves over 150,000
patrons a year sir co-owner Natalie
tells people following use of the
lawsuit not eject Natalie suck a dick no
that was Diana oh [ __ ] yeah nothing is
more important to us than the care and
enjoyment of our patrons we have
maintained our a rating from the
department of health and regular checks
from the health department we have no
record of this ever happening from two
years ago in 2017 honestly I love an
opportunity to slam at Lisa Vanderpump
but I agree this is the since then you
can't talk about something from two
years ago but at the same time with
homegirl did [ __ ] her pants she wouldn't
have told the waitress she would have
ran out so of course they have no record
of it no but like they what what did she
do afterwards and why now two years ago
where we just two years later are we
just hearing about it also like maybe
other people will come forward and say
they got food poisoning from Sur but
until that happens this sounds like it
there's a million things that it could
have been that aren't it actually let's
be really annoying for like so much you
just make a blanket statement and then
like everyone picks up the article like
slide really like affects your business
that it's actually really [ __ ]
annoying yeah so I understand why
they're pissed and they're like slamming
this girl because if it's not true which
right now I mean why would it be like
this is a reach this is a reach for sure
yeah reaching vibes and I don't like
rich you guys ok the other Vanderpump
news is that Jax has unfollowed Kristen
Ariana and Tom Sandoval after seizing a
season 8 filming has wrapped it looks
like there's trouble in Vanderpump rules
paradise just as the cast wrapped up
filming on the season 8 Bravo hit show
Jax Taylor is seemingly feuding with
co-stars Kristen Dodie Ariana Maddox and
Tom Sandoval
according to eagle-eyed fans on social
media as of August 20th he is no longer
following them I know but you know what
people now in reality TV I've been using
like the unfollow button a little too
like loosely because also everyone was
saying like Stassi didn't follow Kristen
anymore and Kristen never posted for an
engagement and I was like oh the
relationships over but then Kristen was
just tweeting that Stassi yesterday us
on Twitter like they're fine yeah maybe
like in that moment that know the
Kristen's house key thing was was
[ __ ] weird
sure and I understand Jackson following
Ariana and
because like in the past they've been
kind of not good friends - yeah um but
Kristen is well Kristen and Jax have
always really gotten along a little too
well hey but I feel like they're kindred
spirits a little bit so is Jax on the
outs with the group right and now it's
not on this show they done filming oh
yeah they just had a wrap party yeah but
I guess that means it'll come up in the
reunion that's always what happens like
[ __ ] you know but that's always like
there's always a break after filming I'm
like so much happens especially with the
Vanderpump rules kids that they all come
back to the reunion like not where they
were at the finale and it's very
confused ya know like right now he's
probably unfollowed them they'll make up
they'll get into a different fight with
someone else by the time we get to the
reunion and then they see what they said
about each other on the show like right
who knows where we'll be it's like we've
come such a long way yeah I really hope
they get the turnaround time on this
season of Vanderpump rules down pat like
anything after I'm gonna be generous
here at November unacceptable I agree
if love island can do it in a day you
can do it if big brother can stream it
live yeah well nobody still has edit it
and make it like exciting so love island
was an edited show they filmed in Fiji
so that they were a day ahead so that
what they were filming there that day
aired here that same day for us oh
that's so and they're like and it's not
live stream so they're splicing it up
and they're making a dramatic and they
have interviews recorded like figure it
out Bravo that's very interesting
Bravo does need to get their turnaround
time like Shahs of Sunset comes on every
three years totally and it goes on for a
year and it's so good and then then you
forget about it like whatever happened
to that good show shows a sunset and
then you see a commercial for it and
like oh I forgot yes yeah 100% shows a
sunset has the weirdest that and Joe be
tardy have the weirdest Bravo scheduling
program we've got to get it together
okay my two cents
okay fifth and final story a little
business a little what business it's
pertinent to the situation um and hits
home for me hmm biz news from Hollywood
Life know from chatter that Dan from
paroles from Hollywood okay the
applecart is here and it's designed to
keep you on your iPhone with iPhone
sales cooling around the world Apple has
a clear goal as evidenced by a slew of
new products and services rolling out in
the back half of this year
keep iphone users glued to their phones
and the Apple ecosystem reports that the
company is looking to spend as much as
six billion dollars on original content
for its forthcoming streaming platform
our one way that they're doing that but
another is the Apple card a much typed
credit card in partnership with Goldman
Sachs and MasterCard that represents a
new for a for the consumer electrons
gents in the services electrons giants
electronics giants in the services space
can you explain I don't go to Apple is
coming up with a credit card so what
it's a partnership with MasterCard yeah
and Goldman Sachs I guess cause like
they need banking yeah they're not a
bank right um but that way people make
even more purchases on their phone oh
and I bet I'll be so easy to use on
Apple pay I don't understand like why
Apple pay doesn't suffice yeah but maybe
they'll not make it even easier but
knows their card instead of like yeah
now you're banking with Apple and I bet
so many people use Apple pay that
they're like we're getting we're losing
all this data like to MasterCard and I'm
a hundred percent honestly if I get this
card I may get this card but you know
recently as two days ago yes my credit
card information was I guess snatched
because I had a fraudulent you edit your
identity stolen and my sort of I don't
know what's going on but an involved
Apple because on Monday an email saying
like your orders been confirmed and I'm
like looking Chucky maybe the person who
stole your identity watching the show
it's like honestly I would shut up
really yeah identity fraud it's not
something to joke about but I don't they
I have a theory as to what happened I
know I should I let me support just so
that we can get to the bottom of it and
the woman at Apple told me to file a pre
support and then you know what the
police have better things to do like
don't bother them I know but like I
think I know the exact place where this
one I know I know you know I'm like
other people should know but I don't
want to see like slander businesses just
one where you put on their Yelp but like
what if it's not true I don't know I
don't give the details of your identity
fraud like you're just giving the
fraudulent person like the confirmation
I just found this it was interesting
because I know it's very interested
credit card fraudulent experience with
Apple concerning Apple and now Apple
seong-gu credit card makes you think oh
my god totally do you think but I
actually think this might be a good idea
and I actually would get it I love
opening credit card said when I first
met TPG member and we only had debit
cards and we were like what are credit
cards now I've like six yeah the card
will also be a physical credit card but
they're gonna incentivize people to use
it through Apple pay so then you're
literally like thank you like Apple has
your money and
takes that's a every every popular app
like tries to make banking work then the
ones snapchat so you could send money
yeah we're like no we can't and then to
like sometimes if you're on Gmail you
could accidentally send someone like
five dollars that's crazy
it's so stupid Facebook too we have
gifts that this actually sounds like oh
my god Facebook gifts when I was in high
school one of our friends had an older
boyfriend like they were like we
couldn't get over that like she had this
like manly boyfriend there honestly they
didn't work out but they were really
cute level and they work together for a
really long time and when it came for
like their birthdays or I was their
anniversary like we were all helping her
like at her older man gift she got in my
fancy golf shoes were like what do you
get an adult am like two years older but
still and he also had like long hair he
like you know home talking right he like
looks like a man so we were like what
are you gonna get him and we like all
she got custom golf shoes it was like
four inch dollars like we were like when
we were in high school we're like this
is the biggest sale ever I'm like what
is he gonna get Oh give me a ring and he
ends up getting her a $10 Starbucks gift
certificate on Facebook and I think
that's where the relationship really was
was broken and it's crazy that they say
chivalry is dead okay because these are
water in that cup a little bit like I
had not been keeping up on my liquid ID
and I'm having dry mouth because of it
Oh what is you do insist liquid maybe is
the fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated for some of you thirsty [ __ ]
out there I think this could be good for
you if you're trying to drink more water
like what I be hydrates you two to three
times faster and more efficiently than
your water alone with an added bonus of
vitamin C b3 b5 b6 and b12 I'm always
talking about the struggle to drink
water because like all I want to juice
drink soda so if I'm gonna drink water I
want it to be multi beneficial you
wanted to be working for you know not
only that it's like I only want to get
hydrated I want to get b6 b12 b53 and
vitamin C b12 is the stuff look what IV
also has a giveback mission they feel
good and do good like what IV has shown
did one and a half a million sticks to
date took places like Haiti Uganda
Puerto Rico and most recently Nepal with
each purchase you make liquid IV donates
a serving to someone in need around the
world that's what's so great it's like
we obviously need it but like people who
have such limited resources to get
hydrated and then also get like a
multipack of vitamins like that's
everything staying properly hydrated is
one of those important factors during
the hot summer months here we are riding
a heat wave and the perfect way to stay
hydrated about spending more time
outdoors even though I spend more time
indoors it still it works
it's a fastest-growing wellness brand
you can find them everywhere even Costco
you can find their hydration multiplier
sold at all cost coats nationwide and
their products utilize cellular
transport technology US industry people
we just call it CTA
it's a specific ratio of glucose which
is sugar cane sodium and potassium when
mixed with water it helps your body
absorb more of the water and nutrients
you drink directly into your bloodstream
we love liquid IV and we've been using
them for a super long time and we know
you will too right now our listeners
will get 25% off at liquid IV dot-com
and when you use our code toes to
checkout
that's 25% off anything you water on
liquid IVs website so go to liquid ID
comm enter promo code toast to get your
savings and start getting better
hydrated that's liquid IV dot-com promo
code toast
don't wait start properly hydrating
today Simon hydrate amazing I thought
I'd love ah I feel like we haven't
talked about liquid IV in a while and
it's just if you're a new toaster like
get on it it's incredible also like I
know it's for hydration but it's also
great for oversight while you're
drinking for hangovers um it's just a
good thing to have in your life you've
taken a lover okay know people are
sharing their interesting gift card
stories gave me a Starbucks gift card
for 99 cents on it but I didn't know and
went to treat my family to coffee and
was completely embarrassed that's so
embarrassing
99 cents you can't get anything at
Starbucks for 99 cents
uh max you're done I think you'd get
like one of those things at the front
like no 99 cents nothing in this world
is nice tax so true maybe a piece of gum
like maybe a gumball in the machine 25
cents yeah it's still 25 cents I think
with inflation it might have gone up no
I think it's still 25 cents
I would be able to check I wouldn't be
surprised well I think that those things
are pretty much out of order like the
only people who have them who have
gumball machines like have it ironically
and there's still little school 25 cent
one okay and I think it's actually free
because it's like you know how to charge
people in your house but yeah it's
actually a great way to make money so
you wanna come to my house sure you
gotta pay 25 cents per gumball
yeah interesting no nothing at Starbucks
is aichi cuz like even if it cost that
much
Starbucks charges more like they're the
devil's brew what do you think is you
know it's like the nation's leading
trash yeah shame they're the leading
purveyors of trust it's like you know
when like you see is okay let's say
you're on a long trip oh this is such a
fun game okay let's say you're on a long
trip like a journey to Atlantic City
and you know happening all day and
you're looking for a rest stop and I
love rest stops like especially like the
clean ones like that are brand new and
you see the sign with all the chains
that it has on it you see a Starbucks
you get excited
no no but let's say let's build our own
dream chain right I only really need
like one thing and also in general like
a Hudson news situation is great like a
no meaning you're not playing the game
okay I want to be to survive chains
7-eleven Dunkin Donuts McDonald's Baskin
Robbins and I don't know maybe Pizza Hut
if I'm feeling for Italian okay mine is
gonna be Sbarro okay hmm
oh but you know now right Burger King
has seemed possible
oh so yeah you can switch out McDonald's
no I [ __ ] love me Tom yeah McDonald's
is my second one I'm gonna go a little
crazy and get a California Pizza Kitchen
that's not a chain that's why some
people like to say it's not a rest stop
chain no okay please I'm gonna get a no
but okay sorry so I have McDonald's and
Sbarro then I would really love a like
an ice cream candy like does it taste
see delight account
no fine okay Baskin Robbins say if
soft-serve no stop okay okay and then I
would definitely oh okay but okay I
can't do like an Applebee's you can meet
appellees is a chain but it's not it's a
seated restaurant yeah okay I look like
a newfound respect from Applebee's after
stagecoach of me and Ben on our way home
from Vermont went to the cleanest like I
could have licked to the floor it was
the most amazing Applebee's ever
Applebee's and fifth and final mmm-hmm
honestly you gotta have a healthy option
Chipotle okay to meet up Chipotle's
healthy it is yeah you could they have
lettuce well I don't get my toes but
it's still healthier than having [ __ ]
chicken nuggets from McDonald's I don't
know I love chicken nuggets like
McDonald's becoming a partner with uber
eats was like the scariest thing that
ever happened to me because I used to
live across the street from one and it
was that probably the lowest point of my
life I was running McDonald's like
multiple times a week also I don't know
if we've reported McDonnells having
impossible burger options yet I don't
think things come around no they have it
but do you know that
Burger King now has a nationwide and
they are now adore - partner so sick
they'd that uber eats a McDonald's
partnered up door - and Burger King and
honestly it might be worth downloading
door - for that it might be but I want
to go I want to get it in the store I
want the full experience
I want to swap out something the Baskin
Robbins first uh like voila oh wow
that's great while I say what should I
say I thought I could only do one I
would do well I beat you because they
have snacks they have real food they
have [ __ ] mac and cheese sandwiches
ice cream those milkshakes yeah while
was such a great chain and it's so crazy
because I think it's like a North East
chain yeah so for those who don't know
it's like a much more elevated bigger
better 7-eleven yeah great just 7-eleven
have sandwiches like that you can custom
make I don't think so I don't think so
it's too scary to think about
voila sweet yeah nice okay well also
Panda Express no I can live without it
on the road it's a little heavy ya know
so also a little dangerous yeah yeah
associate polo though right
okay thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so make sure you
subscribe because this video a thumbs up
and we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher leave a server
you leave the supply stars subscribe we
love you love you love you also new
episode of the snatcher will be out
today hopefully on itunes but i don't
think it's gonna be back in time I
really apologize to that that's that's
my problem and that's it we gotta go
record it I can't wait
we'll see tomorrow
you